the democrats are trying to federalize
our elections
right now the states run the elections
per the constitution but the problem
with that system is that sometimes
republicans win those elections which
the democrats don't like very much so
they have made it their number one
legislative priority to end the
filibuster which will allow them to take
over the elections
and give themselves a major if not a
permanent electoral advantage
they don't have many very good arguments
as to why we should do this beyond their
naked desire for power so instead of
making an argument as to why we need to
completely up end our election system
they are resorting to the tried and true
tactic
of accusing anyone who opposes them of
racism
how do you want to be remembered
at consequential moments in history
they present a choice
do you want to be the sign the side of
dr king
or george wallace
do you want to be in the side of john
lewis
or bull connor
do you want to be the side of abraham
lincoln or jefferson davis
this is the moment to decide
to defend our elections to defend our
democracy
where are you some sort of racist you
want to be on the side of my good
friends strom thurman and robert byrd
the exalted cyclops of the ku klux klan
whoops i mean if you don't want to
completely upend our election system and
give the ruling class in washington d.c
the ability to permanently enthrone
itself at power
according to joe biden then you are a
vile racist
worthy of ostracism but unfortunately
for joe biden
biden is very old and he's been around
for a very long time since george
wallace was governor in fact
and back in the old days when he was
palling around with those actual
segregationists and klansmen joe biden
used to make the opposite sort of
arguments that he's making now and
unfortunately for joe biden we've got
the video
i'm michael knowles and this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from uk ish nzir
who says i'm 16 and my parents don't
want me watching youtube anymore because
they think that you are misinformation
they refuse to actually watch your show
i can see that you're showing more of
the experts than what the mainstream
media does here in new zealand well
thank you very much i appreciate that
i'm not surprised that your parents
don't want you to watch the show
because they've never seen the show
before so they have this vision of what
a right-wing conservative show is like
and they they don't want you to watch it
if they actually did watch it i suspect
they would watch the show themselves
because we spend a lot of our time
exposing the lies of the media that they
are actually consuming so
you're clearly an intelligent person
curious think for yourself seek out the
truth you should always seek out the
truth no matter what the authorities in
your life tell you to do but you should
also honor your father and mother so how
do you
reconcile these things well it's very
simple
if your parents say
i demand you son you cannot watch
youtube anymore because i don't want you
watching that nasty michael knowles you
can say all right mommy and daddy i
understand
i am obedient i'm a good son
and then just go download the podcast on
apple podcasts or spotify or stitcher or
google play
maybe you go over check it out on
dailywire.com you can there are a lot of
places you can get this show okay and
then you honor your father and mother
but you make sure you get the truth
as well and that'll someday when your
parents figure that out this will be a
kind of funny memory hopefully by that
time they'll already be full all-access
subscribers and you can remember that
wonderful that wonderful memory when you
want to cherish your memories forever
and ever and ever i would strongly
recommend you check out paint your life
the simplest thing that you can do
to your home to improve your day-to-day
life it's one thing a lot of people
overlook it
put beautiful art on the walls
we
are human beings we have artistic
longings we love beauty put beautiful
things on the walls it's going to make
your life a lot better what if those
beautiful things could be cherished
memories from your life a cherished
person a pet a place some great picture
that you all had with paint your life
you can get that you can get a
professional hand-painted portrait
created from any photo or multiple
photos at an incredibly affordable price
you can combine the photos they will
work with you these world-class artists
will work with you until every detail is
perfect i had one made a year or two ago
of my mother
i bugged this artist until kingdom come
about well i think the background should
maybe be like this i know it's not like
that in the picture but this and they
come out beautifully the art is
incredibly beautiful i love it at
paintyourlife.com there is no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is refunded guaranteed right now
is a limited time offer get 20 off your
painting that is 20 off and free
shipping to get this special offer text
the word michael mich ael to four
thousand that's michael m-i-c-h-a-e-l to
sixty-four thousand
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most term supply available
at painterlife.com terms again text
michael m-i-c-h-a-e-l to sixty-four
thousand
the democrats this is a little this is a
two-part process so i understand why
it's a little bit confusing the
democrats want to take over the
elections
they can't take over the elections right
now because
even though they have a majority in the
senate and in the congress they only
have a very slim majority
so
in the senate because there's something
called the filibuster you need more than
just a slim majority you need 60 votes
to be able to actually push these really
radical proposals through so the
democrats need to end the filibuster
filibuster long-standing senate
tradition
but joe biden says it doesn't matter
however you got to do it this is our
chance to really grab some power so
whatever you got to do you need
to end
the filibuster here's joe biden in his
own words
we should make no mistake
this nuclear option
is ultimately an example of the
arrogance of power
it is a fundamental power grab
by
the majority party oh whoopsy daisy that
was 17 years ago sorry that was back
when joe biden was a senator and was
arguing against getting rid of the
filibuster because he said it was a
naked grab of power it was a threat to
american democracy would turn us into a
banana republic
but that was then and this is now that
was when the republicans were in power
and wanted to do it and
now because the democrats are in power
it's a completely different story
today
i'm making it clear
to protect our democracy
i support changing the senate rules
whichever way they need to be changed to
prevent
a minority of senators from blocking
action on voting rights
when it comes to protecting majority
rule in america the majority should rule
in the united states senate
i make this announcement with careful
deliberation recognizing the fundamental
right to vote is a right from which all
other rights flow
biden in 2005 it's very important that
we don't have simple majority rule
that's not the way america is governed
this is a bare naked power grab this is
terrible this is a threat to our
democracy joe biden in 2022 we
absolutely need bare majority rule in
america if we don't have bear majority
rule as we haven't ever if we if we
don't change that all right now then
that would be a threat to our democracy
that would be a terrible naked paragraph
and so okay right joe biden is not
making any good faith arguments here he
is as he described 17 years ago just
trying to take power and he's using a
lot of mealy-mouthed euphemisms to do it
this is my favorite one that you're
hearing right now from
democrats they say we need action on
voting rights
we need action right now on voting
rights
what action do we need what
what action do we need and why do we
need that action
what they mean by the action that we
need on voting rights is we need to take
away voter id laws we need to make it
easier for illegal aliens for foreign
citizens to vote in our elections we
need to make it easier for democrat
operatives to cheat because they're just
going to send out unsolicited mail-in
ballots to everyone who's ever
registered anywhere and you're gonna
you're gonna have multiple ballots going
to people at different addresses you're
this is what's what happened in
california just during this recent
recall election people such as my
colleagues here at the daily wire moved
out of california many of us said do not
send me a ballot what happens they send
you a ballot anyway because widespread
mail-ins are totally open to fraud even
barack obama admitted this just a few
years ago
before the democrats pivoted on it and
tried to do it so they're pushing for
specific actions that will not protect
the right to vote but actually
weaken the right to vote and weaken
integrity in our system don't forget
every time an ineligible voter votes
they're taking away a vote from an
eligible voter
so that's that's the what
and and what's crazier than the what is
the why
why why do we need action on voting
rights is there anyone in america right
now who is an ineligible who is an
eligible voter rather who can't vote
who
show me the person
it has never been easier to vote
frankly it's a little too easy to vote
that's that's really the problem
you don't only need to vote on election
day
virtually everywhere in the country you
can vote on multiple days all you can
say you can send in mail-in ballots if
you want if you request a mail-in ballot
these days you can just get a mail-in
ballot without even requesting it
you'll have
vote harvesters showing up to your door
to take your ballots in many cases
certainly in democrat priests it's never
been who can't vote
which show me the eligible voter who
can't vote
they can't do it
and so they have to use these ridiculous
euphemisms we need action
it's a crisis
what they're suggesting is that the clan
is outside of every polling place
intimidating black voters
doesn't happen doesn't happen anywhere
in the country in fact the only recent
evidence of voter intimidation that
we've seen was about 10 years ago during
the obama administration when the new
black panther party was showing up with
guns outside of polling places so it was
voter intimidation from the left you're
not seeing it
from
far right
fascist
neo nazi any you're not seeing any that
just doesn't exist so it's a completely
made-up problem and then democrats are
promote through their propagandists in
the media largely are
promoting that made-up problem so that
they can come in with a solution which
is to give themselves a whole lot more
power
this reminds me a lot of what they've
done with covid
namely
they have set up a fantasy that
justifies their policies policies that
might actually be justified if the
premise were true in the first place if
there were
americans dropping perfectly healthy
ordinary americans dropping like flies
it's not just very specific groups of
people that we need to protect from the
virus that we can protect but everyone
all young people healthy people they
were dropping like flies thousand nine
hundred thousand a million
hundred thousand kids on ventilators
like sonia sotomayor said if that were
true
that would justify a much more
aggressive reaction to kovit the problem
is none of that's true it's just
completely made up and so
their policies are not justified if
millions and millions of eligible voters
in america were being unjustly kept away
from the polls then that would justify
action on voting rights but that's not
happening it's just completely made up
and so it doesn't justify that
if we had a system of government in
america that was supposed to be simple
majority rule then i guess that would
justify
protecting majority rules simple
majority rule but that's not what we
have in america we have an elaborate
constitutional system of government that
has a separation of powers and has
checks and balances and has elements of
democracy it has elements of aristocracy
it has elements of monarchy for goodness
sakes it has elements that are extremely
democratic it has elements that are much
less democratic it has an executive a
legislature and a judiciary it has
federal power state power which the feds
are now trying to completely take away
and power that is reserved by the people
and you've got a ruling class
clumped in the feds in the federal
bureaucracy and in the federal
government that's trying to take all the
power away from all of the other
branches and all of the other
all of the other power centers in the
country
and they might get away with it
the the only thing i've gotten away with
recently is i've had the opportunity to
get auto parts at a really reduced price
which is why i would strongly recommend
you check out rock auto new year
everyone's busy we got to get back to
work you probably are a little tight on
time so do you want to spend your time
hanging with your family getting your
job done fixing up things around the
house or do you want to spend your time
waiting in line at the brick and mortar
auto parts store driving over there
waiting in line
getting peppered with a thousand
questions about your car the guy goes in
the back he doesn't have to park because
there's too many parts these days to
stock
he comes back out he tells you you got
to order it you wait two weeks you get
the no you don't want that you want to
go to rockauto.com
right now you go to rockauto.com you see
all the parts available for your car or
truck the website is so simple to use
even i can do it you can get the same
prices for pros as for do-it-yourselfers
you're not gonna have a ton of gimmicks
all over the place oh you log in on
tuesday morning and you'll save 12
percent no it's always reliably low
prices from a family business
rockauto.com see all those parts
available for your car truck then write
noel scanner wles in there how did you
hear about his box so they know that we
sent you you want to talk about a fed
power grab you want to talk about a
charade
let's talk about
january 6th i'm not making any
accusations i'm only you know i'm sorry
i didn't say it right
let's talk about january 6th
the worst insurrection
and
terror attack in the history of the
united states january 6. so
what we're told is that
these trump supporters showed up and
they killed a bunch of cops and they
nearly took down the government none of
that was true
the worst they did was cause some
property damage
and
the horn hat guy danced around the
capital
but now we're learning
the feds
may have had an
active role
in promoting the riot at the capitol
senator ted cruz yesterday was grilling
the fbi in a senate hearing and he had a
very simple question this should not be
complicated it should have been a very
simple answer
did any fbi agents or fbi informants
commit acts of violence on january 6th
ms sandberg
i want to turn to the fbi
how many fbi agents
or confidential informants actively
participated in the events of january
6th
sir i'm sure you can appreciate that i
can't go into the specifics of sources
and methods uh did any fbi agents or
confidential informants actively
participate in the events of january 6th
yes or no yes or no sir i can't i can't
answer that
did any fbi agents or confidential
informants commit crimes of violence on
january 6th
6th
i can't answer that sir
did any fbi agents or fbi informants
actively encourage and incite crimes of
violence on january 6th 26th sir i can't
answer that sir i can't answer sir i
can't answer sir i can't answer but
notice the way she didn't answer changed
and this does remind you i don't say it
just because he's a friend of mine and
we host a podcast together does remind
you that cruz is a very good lawyer
because you would think that the first
question he would ask is did the fbi
have any involvement in january 6th
that's the basic question to establish
but he he doesn't
the first question he asks is
how many feds were involved
right he's sort of talking past the sale
here
he's assuming that the feds certainly
were involved and he's saying so how
many it says how many
fbi agents or confidential informants
were involved in january 6th
and what is her answer she says
sir i can't reveal sources or methods
so she's accepting the premise that the
feds were involved in january 6 because
if no feds were involved if the fbi
really did not have its fingerprints on
january 6th
then she could have just said we weren't
involved
that's fine that doesn't compromise any
agents in the field that doesn't
compromise any informants
that's a that's a very simple answer she
certainly can give that answer we were
not involved
but she doesn't
because
he assumes that they were and she allows
him to get away with it
she allows him to play that trick
because he had a good hunch and he was
right
so she says i can't reveal sources or
methods he goes okay then he goes back
he says were there any involved um
uh
i can't answer that
yeah you can't answer it because you
were involved that's why
it's a big yes
it's a big fat yes
so the question then becomes what was
the fbi's involvement
was the fbi's involvement just to gather
some information
that's a totally legal law enforcement
tactic
or was the fbi's involvement
to incite
violence was the fbi's involvement not
just to gather information about what
was already happening but was the fbi's
involvement to actually cause these
events to happen in the first place
because the fbi is not allowed to do
that no law enforcement agency is
allowed to do that slight parenthetical
here i know senator cruz got in a lot of
trouble last week because he used a dumb
talking point from the democrats to
describe january 6th and a lot of people
wrote in to me and they said michael
when are you gonna toss this guy
overboard when are you going to call out
your friend ted cruz when are you going
to go after your friend ted cruz and i
haven't really i certainly haven't on
the show i was on c-span over the
weekend and i addressed it because i was
i was asked about it on on tv but i'm
happy to address it here which is
i i generally don't
endeavor to throw my friends under the
bus
i don't think anyone should endeavor to
throw their friends under the bus there
are some occasions where someone is
doing something that is so bad that
you've got to call them out for it
or if they're unrepentant or if they're
going down a really bad path
of course then you have an obligation to
justice to say hey this is wrong and
maybe you do it privately at first but
then you can do it publicly afterward
but if someone makes a mistake and then
recognizes it was a mistake and the
wrong thing to do and then acknowledges
that publicly i don't think that
conservatives or anyone else has the
obligation or even
really should just throw someone under
the bus
in a in a graceless way
because my argument at the time i
thought look not just because the guy's
a friend of mine but because as a member
of the conservative
movement ted cruz has been a good
senator
he's been one of the
most stalwart one of the most
conservative one of the most effective
senators we've got
so if he says a dumb thing and he
acknowledges it and he says yeah whoops
i shouldn't have done that i was dumb
we're just gonna
throw him overboard i don't that to me
doesn't seem like a very effective
political strategy
if that's the new standard that anytime
any of our fighters out there do
anything dumb or bad or make any mistake
that we're just gonna say okay you're
gone out of darkness wailing and
gnashing feet see you later then
conservatives are never gonna be able to
practically accomplish anything
but i don't know i thought okay am i
just am i just being too nice to my
friend here
am i just am i am i showing too much
grace here is he does ted cruz suddenly
become a huge squish and he's just
completely useless and he's he's liz
cheney and a wig or something and then
just a few days later we see no the guy
is still one of the most stalwart
right-wing effective
conservatives in the senate and how did
he do it because he nailed the feds on
the january 6th thing specifically on
that issue
and then he brought up a very important
name
this is a name maybe you've heard about
him on twitter or on some of the message
boards
or maybe some conservative news outlet
but it's not a name that's gone
mainstream ted cruz asked
who is ray epps
who is ray epps
yep
i'm aware of the individual sir uh
i don't have the specific background to
him
well there are a lot of people who are
understandably very concerned about mr f
on the night of january 5th
2021 epps wandered around the crowd that
had gathered
and there's video out there of him
channing tomorrow we need to get into
the capital into the capital
this was strange behavior so strange
that the crowd began chanting fed fed
fed fed fed fed
miss sandburn was ray epstein
sir i cannot answer that question
the next day the next day on january 6
mr epps is seen whispering to a person
and five seconds later five seconds
after he's whispering to a person that
same person begins to forcibly tear down
the barricades
so miss fbi lady is reyes a fed
sir i cannot answer that question yeah i
bet you can't well i bet you can i think
you just don't want to cruz goes on
he
explains another really strange fact
which is that in the days after january
6th the fbi puts this guy ray epps on a
most wanted list his picture there
says if you can find this person if you
can you know there were a number of
other people on the list as well if you
can find them any information leading to
their arrest please send it over and
then when when they discover one of
these people they slap a big label
arrested we got him right
except for ray epps
ray epps suddenly disappears from the
fbi website
reyes disappears from the fbi website
just a day or two after
a right-wing media outlet revolver news
publishes
a report suggesting that reyes is a fed
all of a sudden epps is gone he wasn't
arrested if he had been arrested there
would have been a big sign that arrested
right on him
he just disappears
suspect israel's fed i don't know
regardless of whether he is or not the
fbi has a lot of explaining to do
they're now in total damage control mode
by the way the january 6th committee and
the two squish fake republicans adam
kinzinger and liz cheney are trying
desperately in these extremely lawyered
carefully worded parsing every single
syllable statements to insinuate that
this guy's not a fed
the testimony does not seem convincing
representative thomas massey pressed
attorney general merrick garland on the
same question he said hey buster there's
a lot of strange behavior with this eps
guy
what's going on is he one of you
as far as we can determine the
individual who was saying he'll probably
go to jail he'll probably be arrested
but he wants every but they need to go
into the capitol the next day is then
the next day directing people to the
capitol and as far as we can find this
individual has not been charged with
anything you said this is one of the
most sweeping investigations in the
history
have you seen that video or
those frames from that video
so as i
said at the outset uh one of the norms
of the justice department is to not
comment on impending investigations and
particularly not to comment about
particular scenes or particular
individuals this okay without i was
hoping today to give you an opportunity
to put to rest
the concerns that people have that there
were federal agents or assets of the
federal government present on january
5th and january 6th can you tell us
without talking about particular
incidents or particular videos how many
agents or assets of the federal
government were present on january 6
whether they agitated to go into the
capital and if any of them did
so i'm not going to violate this norm
of the rule of law you don't need to
violate any norms if you weren't
involved buster it's very simple if you
guys didn't have your fingers all over
it then you can say we weren't involved
but you did you obviously did which is
why it would violate your norms and
compromise your sources and your agents
and your informants for you to to get
into the details because we already have
the answer to the basic questions were
the feds involved in january 6th 100 of
the evidence says
yes
talk about corruption in our federal
government talk about doing the same
thing over and over and over again you
know what ben's show us about today it's
about how hillary might run for
president
again can you imagine that she might run
i hope she does i hope she does just so
we get the pleasure of beating her again
a whole lot more coming up don't go
anywhere i'm michael knowles we'll be
right back
so cruz
representative thomas massey
other people
have
presented a lot of evidence
that the feds were involved in january 6
and the capital riot what does this show
us
one i think it's safe to assume that
that is the case i think the fbi
testimony and attorney general merrick
garland's testimony basically proved it
because if they hadn't been involved
they could have just said so
so it shows you that a whole lot of
american politics
is a charade
it's political theater what it shows you
is a lot of the political battles that
we think define the way our government
and society work
they're actually just a distraction
and you can look at
the blm riots
or the capitol ride for that matter and
you think okay our big national battle
it's between antifa
on one hand and the proud boys
or the oath keepers which i think is
just a completely made-up organization
yeah it's between them that's where the
real fight's going on uh no
i don't think that's quite right because
the
current occupant of the white house and
his vice president
were supporting indirectly and directly
the antifa and blm riders kamala harris
raised money to bail them out of prison
they even out of jail rather
the federal government seems to have
been inciting the right-wing rioters at
the capitol they certainly were were
involved to some degree
according to all the evidence available
to us
so
both sides of that alleged battle are
really just kind of being orchestrated
out of washington dc
by the ruling class huh that's weird
the republicans versus the democrats
very often it seems that no matter who
you elect you get the same bad policy
the same exact sort of bad policy the
country keeps going in the wrong
direction no matter who you that's weird
it's almost as if
much of our
mainstream political
battling
is just fake
it's just a show
while the actual business of government
takes place behind the scenes usually
with all of those alleged belligerents
working
together
we do not have
powerful
organized
institutionalized opposition
in this country to the liberal
establishment to the ruling class you
want to see a great example of this jake
tapper
on cnn
just expressed his outrage his dismay
that the cdc
seems to have misrepresented data on the
coronavirus the hospitals are still
stretched in because of this so i'm not
trying to take away from that but if 40
in some hospitals 40 of the people who
have coveted
don't necessarily have problematic covet
they're there because they got in a car
accident they're there because right um
you know they they bump their head
and they're being included as in the
hospital with covid that number seems
kind of misleading we're two years into
this and
we need the clearest picture possible if
somebody's in the hospital with a broken
leg and they also have asymptomatic
ovarian that should not be counted as
hospitalized with covet clearly
i can't believe you how dare you cdc how
dare you government officials
just just present this data in a
misleading way
where were the journalists where were
all the journalists to ask you these
questions two years ago when when when
we all just believe oh wait wait that's
right i'm a journalist oops
right i was supposed to be the one
asking those questions i'm glad that
jake tapper is either outraged or
pretending to be outraged now because
the establishment and the ruling class
was lying to us for two years some of us
by the way i hate to say i told you so
some of us were calling this
two years ago
but i'm glad jake tapper has caught up
now he should have been doing that the
whole time that's what an actual
journalist would have done
that's what
someone who's really
speaking truth to power and asking the
hard questions that's what they would
have done but that's that's not what
happened with our corporate media
because our corporate press are not
actually investigative reporters and
journalists and fighting back against
the entrenched power they're part of the
entrenched power
they're the same thing
the the progressives in our government
the hardcore progressives are not there
fighting against and sticking it to the
big corporations they're
working with the big corporations
they're all on the same side
and they're not getting asked the
questions of the media and they're not
having their
premises questioned by the intellectuals
in the academy that the the people who
are
doing research on their own the
scientists and the other sorts of
scholars who are also speaking truth to
power no they're all they're all just
working together
they're all just part of the same thing
and
whenever they appear to be in opposition
that's
almost always just political theater
the question is now why is jake tapper
suddenly changing his tune
well it's not just jake tapper it's
it's the whole
ruling class
do you think it's a coincidence that cnn
is now taking a more skeptical
more
i don't know calm
more reasonable approach to covid
at the very same time that joe biden is
trying to pivot on kovid and joe biden
is saying look there's no federal
solution here look we're all just going
to have to get back to normal at the
very same time that the democrat
governor of new york is saying actually
the hospitalization numbers are being
exaggerated at the very same time as the
cdc director is saying actually the
hospitalization numbers or the death
numbers rather have been somewhat
exaggerated because of the issue of
comorbidities do you think it's just a
coincidence
that all of these various facets of
society many of which are supposed to be
pitted in opposition to one another are
just all of a sudden changing their tune
at the same time because why
because that is now in the interest of
the ruling class which has many
different facets to it
that's why because there are diminishing
political returns for the lockdowns and
forcing everyone to get the constant
jabs and and harping on kovid forever
and ever and ever
they've already seized the power that
they wanted to seize they've already
upended our society they've already
taken away of a lot of our liberties and
so they're all going to pivot and move
on to the next thing
and they're going to do it in concert
with one another
and the most defensive part of all is
they're going to pretend that they're
actually fighting one another the whole
time
they are going to relieve themselves on
your leg and tell you that it is raining
rarely very rarely do you see a
politician
or
or a leader in any of those facets of
our power structures in america whether
that's the media whether that's the
universities whether that's the
corporations rarely do you see a leader
buck
the trend
buck the party line
and you are seeing that a little bit
right now
with ron desantis
ron desantis has just come out
with a number of proposals for the new
legislative session
his proposals include
a major clamping down on
immigration
now ron desantis as a governor he's not
the president so he's a governor he
can't do very much about legal
immigration that that's going to be set
at the national level
but he can do a lot about illegal
immigration and what he's proposing is
to ban
state and local agencies from doing
business with any company or
non-governmental organization that helps
facilitate illegal immigration across
florida
so he's going to
use his power
to force the state to pressure
companies and ngos to stop using illegal
labor
he is going to require every county in
florida
to enter into a contract with ice the
immigration enforcement agency
as part of a federal program that
streamlines
getting illegals arrested and deported
he is going to prevent cooperation
between ice agents and law enforcement
agencies he is going to or rather he's
going to stop people from from
law enforcement from working with ice he
is going to implement an emergency order
that
bans the issuance or renewal of all
state licenses to companies or ngos that
provide services to unaccompanied
alien children in florida so this is
really tough stuff
on the issue of immigration and this is
going to irritate not just
democrats
but some republicans as well i'll give
you an example would be the chamber of
commerce
chamber of commerce
there are many republicans who support
the chamber of commerce and many
republicans who the chamber of commerce
supports
has just come out and said they want to
double
legal immigration into the united states
they want to double it
the ceo of the chamber of commerce
suzanne clark says that the chamber's
official position is to double illegal
immigration from two million
or from
around one to two million what it is now
to two
to four million legal immigrants every
single
year
that would be bringing in an annual
foreign-born population that is six
times the size
of boston
every single year now there have been
surveys on this issue of immigration
and
in recent years the american people have
suggested i'm thinking of one
harvard-harris poll in particular that
they don't want to increase the level of
legal immigration they actually want to
drastically reduce both legal and
illegal immigration by 50 60 percent
because we're just taking in too many
people this is the largest movement of
human beings ever in the history of the
world in recorded history
but the democrats and many republicans
support it there are many republicans
who say yeah illegal immigration really
bad we got to secure the border but we
want more legal immigration oh legal
immigration is great we love it even
donald trump who is the most immigration
hawk president we've probably ever had
certainly had in recent decades
he famously said i want to stop illegal
immigration but i want more legal
immigration than ever
why
yes illegal immigration is a particular
problem but
immigration generally is is the problem
right now we just have too much of it
it's no knock on the immigrants we just
have way too much we're not assimilating
people it's keeping wages down for low
low skilled or low-income workers which
is by the way why the chamber of
commerce loves it it's why the
corporations love it it's why the
semi-right-wing corporations love it the
whole ruling class is in on this thing
no matter who you elect you get more
immigration even though the majority of
americans want dramatically less
immigration
seems like a rigged game it seems like a
big charade
on this issue desantis is totally right
the chamber of commerce is totally wrong
and
i think the candidates who are going to
do really well in 2022 and 2024
are not going to be echoing the
left-wing line of more immigration legal
and illegal they're not going to be
echoing the chamber of commerce line or
the even the trump line for that matter
which is no illegal but lots of legal
lots more legal i think that the
candidates who really see where the
future of the american right and the
conservative movement are going will say
we just need less immigration
period
because
most americans want it we've got to
we've got to defend majority rule in our
democracy according to joe biden
because we can't assimilate this many
people this quickly and because a nation
that doesn't have borders and doesn't
respect
the people of its country is no nation
at all
speaking of accompanying children this
is going to be the creepiest segue i've
ever done
please forgive me
the
usa today usa today life in particular
had gotten a little bit of trouble
yesterday because they published an
article and a tweet thread
that appeared to try to normalize
pedophilia
some of us on the right you know hate to
say i told you so
have called it for years
that the left is inevitably going to try
to normalize pedophilia not just because
they are degenerate perverts that's not
that's not why actually
that's not the only reason why but
because the logic of the left on the
sexual revolution requires them to
normalize pedophilia
and that's exactly what this usa today
piece did
the article title was
what the public keeps getting wrong
about pedophilia
you know that much put upon minority
pedophiles you know them there was a
professor who was just fired for trying
to normalize pedophilia tried to
redefine pedophiles as as maps
minor attracted persons
so here's what usa today says what we
think we know we think we know what a
pedophile is there's a lot of
misunderstanding in recent decades the
science on pedophilia has improved one
of the most significant findings is that
pedophilia is likely determined in the
womb though environmental factors may
influence whether someone acts on an
urge to abuse the evidence suggests it
is inborn it's neurological said james
cantor a sex researcher and expert on
pedophilia
could you imagine being an expert on
pedophilia that's
not the kind of expertise you want when
most of the public thinks of pedophilia
they assume it's synonymous with child
sexual abuse a pedophile is an adult
who's sexually attracted to children but
not all pedophiles abuse kids and some
people who sexually abuse kids are not
pedophiles
pedophiles may not have control over the
fact that they're attracted to kids but
they are responsible for what they do or
don't act on says ann salter who's
another pedophile expert
usa today deleted this thread they kept
the article up there they retitled it
they got a lot of backlash
and they got a lot of backlash from
conservatives
somewhat justifiably because they
clearly are trying to normalize
pedophilia but i actually think
conservatives reacted a little too
quickly here
because i think that the principle
that usa today is describing is actually
extremely conservative and i think the
principle that usa today is describing
actually undermines
not just the left argument on
extremely creepy sex stuff like
pedophilia but the left's whole argument
on the sexual revolution
what what usa today has done in this
article almost certainly unwittingly
is defended sexual repression
and conversion therapy
there there were two kinds of backlash i
think to this article the only one we
really saw was the conservative backlash
but think about what what usa today is
saying here they're saying pedophilia is
natural natural meaning it's with you
from the moment you're born it's not
something that's learned necessarily but
something it's a sexual orientation
right that's the difference between a
sexual desire that maybe you develop
over time and a sexual orientation
that's with you from the moment of birth
and you can't change it now is
pedophilia
inborn natural a sexual orientation i
don't know
maybe maybe not that's kind of secondary
to the point
what usa today is saying is
even if
a sexual desire is inborn
even if you're born this way which was
the left's entire argument on the lgbt
movement and ultimately why they
redefine marriage
you still should repress some of those
desires
but hold on we were told if you have a
sexual desire from birth and you can't
change it it's immutable then you should
not repress it that it's very harmful
and unhealthy to repress that desire
that it's immoral to ask someone to
repress that desire because they're born
this way now the conservative argument
was always look people are born with all
sorts of desires it's a fallen world and
some of them you got to repress
but the left said no that's awful that's
retrograde that's terrible
now they seem to be endorsing it
furthermore they're saying these
pedophiles need to go to therapy to try
to mitigate their desires to try to
change their desires
that's just conversion therapy
conversion therapy isn't a real thing
it's a slogan that the left has put on
various psychological and spiritual
programs to try to get people who have
unwanted sexual desires to be able to
repress them somewhat or to mitigate
them or to change them
but they're endorsing that now for the
pedos well why well because pedophilia
is especially bad okay sure but i
thought the argument that you were
making is that it is immoral and unjust
to force someone to repress their urges
and to force someone to try to change
their urges when you can't change those
urges by golly because they're immutable
and it's a sexual orientation so you
told me it was wrong to do that but now
you're saying it's right to do that in
some cases why is it right to do that in
some cases well because
certain sexual desires are simply wrong
michael
is what they're saying
huh
interesting because that's not the art
and by the way i'm not i'm not just uh
picking on the homosexuals here
or the transgenderists or whatever i'm
talking about the whole sexual
revolution we were told we weren't alive
i wasn't alive back then but you can see
it in the literature
in the 1960s 1970s that all sorts of
sexual urges need to be indulged you're
urged to have sex before marriage you're
urged to have sex with multiple people
you're urged to all of these urges they
just you can't stifle them man it's free
love come on just let it out otherwise
you're going to explode no
no of course that was never true
and only because we're taking this issue
to the most logical extreme here
do we see
why that's not true i kind of like the
article i know sorry i don't think that
usa today meant the article to be liked
by
conservatives such as us but i think
they make a very conservative point
speaking of impulses that should be
repressed
multiple states now are discriminating
against white people in covid treatment
according to reporting from the
washington free beacon in new york
racial minorities are automatically
eligible for scarce coveted therapeutics
regardless of their age or underlying
conditions in utah a latinx
ethnicity that's the new word for
mexicans and guatemalans and those sorts
of people account for more than
congestive heart failure
in a patient's covid19 risk score
states framework that then allows for
treatments
in minnesota health officials have
devised their own ethical framework that
prioritizes black 18 year olds over
white 64 year olds
even though
the white 64 year olds are at a much
higher risk of severe disease
where does this come from not just from
the radical left-wing states comes from
the fda the fda says that there is an
emergency use for these treatments for
people who are at high risk and then it
goes further and defines minorities as
being high risk just by virtue of the
color of their skin this is another
reminder
that white supremacy
is not only absurd
it's the opposite of reality
white people are
one of the only groups that you can
legally discriminate against asians also
you can discriminate against in college
admissions
and
white people are the only racial group
that you can socially
condemn and insult and that that is
acceptable and it's actually encouraged
and it's carried out by many prominent
people
what we are told by the ruling class
namely that this is a white supremacist
country and whites have all the
privilege
that isn't true
it's not only silly but if you just look
at our law in the way that our laws are
enforced
the opposite is true
but by design
and
in practice that's happening right now
speaking of racial politics i have to
get to this story
because it's so silly
there is a new series
called
american women quarters they're going to
put women on the back of quarters
and they've just announced the first
american women quarter
and so these you're going to be able to
get these you're going to go out they're
going to be lots of different women on
the back of these quarters the problem
with the women quarters of course is
that they're only worth 19 cents
75 cents on the dollar and so if you do
the calculations only about 19 cents is
what the quarter's worth i assume i
don't know the first quarter that's here
is the maya angelou quarter
maya angelou
who is
a terrible poet she's this poet you
probably read her in school because a
lot of
english teachers really like
a lot of left-wing english teachers
really like presenting her horrible
poetry you've probably heard this one
you may write me down in history with
your bitter twisted lies you may trod me
in the very dirt but still like dust
i'll rise
not exactly wordsworth okay not exactly
shakespeare
but
this this has become very popular
and now she's going to be on the back of
quarters
really she's only on the back of
quarters because she's a black woman and
she uh had a role in left-wing politics
and styled herself a civil rights leader
and that's not just me saying that
that's what all the people who are
promoting this all the blue checks all
the people in government are saying it's
it's so wonderful because she's a black
woman so they're making it all about her
identity this is literal tokenism they
are making her a token like an actual
physical token and it debases everyone
involved it debases the people who
tokenize
it debases the people who are betokened
it debases poetry because this stuff is
really bad and a fifth grader could
write better poetry and
it debases our country to look at one
another this way it's just flesh and
blood and just a color rather than
looking
a little bit deeper as to what we really
are but it shows you the difference
between
the propaganda that comes out of our
rulers on what this country is
and the way things are actually being
done right now they look like they could
be getting
a lot worse i'm michael noels as the
michael knowles you'll see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show